[Musique]
à kaboul les apparences sont parfois
trompeuses
les matins ordinaires peuvent cacher des
réalités plus complexe
parmi ces enfants il est une petite
fille qui n'est déjà plus comme les
autres
depuis quelques mois chabine à 9 ans se
travestit
chaque matin entre les mains de sa mère
elle devient un garçon
ne le sait pas trop où tu me tire les
cheveux
voilà comme ça c'est bien il voit
pitesti je lui mets ça sur la tête parce
qu'elle va travailler dans la rue et
j'ai peur pour elle car c'est une fille
c'est pour ça que je la déguise en
garçon
voilà comme ça je suis un garçon je peux
faire ce que j'ai à faire sans problème
et tu es heureuse comme ça
non mais je n'ai pas le choix je dois le
faire
[Musique]
chamina est ce que les afghans appelle
une bâche à poche une fille habillée
comme un homme
en chat noir qu'a misé ses cheveux
enfermé dans un bonnet elle est aux yeux
des autres un garçon elle gagne ainsi
des droits que les autres vie non pas
comme celui de sortir seul dans la rue
et de travailler
chaque matin elle aide son père à ouvrir
la petite épicerie qui fait vivre la
famille
mais les gâteaux ici contre le mur
[Musique]
son père est lourdement handicapé c'est
pour cela qu'il a fait de l'aîné de ses
enfants une bâche à poche
pauvre enfant elle fait tout à la maison
et ici avec moi
ses deux jambes il les a perdus en
sautant sur une mine qui datait de la
guerre avec les soviétiques elle était
là sur une route il ne l'a pas vu
et maintenant vu que je ne suis plus que
la moitié de moi même je dois faire
travailler ma fille et je ne veux pas
que les gens disent regardez c'est un
incapable il fait travailler sa fille
et puis en afghanistan la vie est dure
pour les filles et je ne veux pas la
perdre quand elle est habillée comme ça
personne ne peut savoir qui elle est
tout le monde pense que c'est un garçon
ça la protège c'est mieux comme ça
c'est la rue qui fait peur aux pères de
chamina celle où elle se rend tous les
jours pour ramasser des papiers qu'elle
revendra ensuite aux recycleurs
[Musique]
elle y retrouve d'autres enfants tous
l'appellent zaid son nom de garçons sont
nombreux
et vous vous n'êtes pas habillés comme
des garçons non
non mon père m'a pas dit de faire ça
mais du coup les gars on me posait
problème il me tape
j'aimerais bien me déguiser en garçon
comme ça ils varient très de m'embêter
à la fin de la journée chabine à rentrer
chez elle son premier geste redevenir mm
pourquoi est ce que tu fais ça mon
travail est fini je ne suis plus à id
l'achat du match
[Musique]
à 9 ans chabine à voudrais être une
petite fille comme les autres mais son
destin a pris un tour différent dans
quelques années qui sait si elle préféra
toujours son voile à son bonnet
[Musique]
combien sont-elles ces filles que leurs
parents travestissent
impossible de le savoir en afghanistan
la pratique est courante mais elles
restent cachés
tradition condamné par l'islam elle est
taboue en cette société marquée par la
domination masculine notre fille est un
fardeau se vêtir comme les hommes un
moyen d'échapper à cette condition
dans les rues dans les classes dans les
stades elles se font passer pour des
garçons pour travailler étudier marché
sans voile courir s'amuser vivre
[Musique]
petit à petit elles apprennent à
s'affranchir
cette liberté gagnée peu sont prêtes à
la rendre quel qu'en soit le prix à
payer
[Musique]
propres mains
mais je me sens vraiment bien ces
vêtements d'homme je suis libre je peux
conduire aller faire des courses
si je m'habille on fille je ne pourrais
rien faire de tout ça
mais je vis avec la peur celle qu'on
découvre qui je suis vraiment une fille
et un garçon et là je pourrais avoir de
gros problèmes
il y a longtemps jacques s'appeler big
kiss c'était une petite fille née dans
une famille sans garçons pour éviter le
déshonneur de ne pas avoir deux fils les
parents avaient fait de leur dernière
fille une bâche à poches puis jacques a
eu des frères mais n'a pas voulu
redevenir bill crise elle a gardé ses
vêtements d'hommes contre l'avis de tous
jacques à 25 ans aujourd'hui
dès l'âge de 3 ans je lai habillé avec
des vêtements de garçons oui c'est sale
n'avait pas plus de trois ans
à l'époque j'avais une admiration pour
jack king kennedy alors je suis donné le
surnom de jack sont un garçon
elle est devenue le fils de la famille
parce que je n'avais pas de fils aîné il
fallait quelqu'un pour s'occuper de la
maison réparer le générateur enlever la
neige du toit aller faire les courses au
bazar jack faisait tout ce qu'un garçon
fait normalement parce que en
afghanistan les familles ont besoin d'un
fils plus que d'une fille
les films ne peuvent rien faire
elle aimait ça millions garçons
et après elle était comme habité par ses
vêtements elle se comportait en garçons
mais quand les talibans sont arrivés
c'était trop dangereux j'ai voulu
qu'elles changent essayé je n'ai même
battus pour ça mais elle ne m'a jamais
écouté
porter des vêtements d'homme pour une
femme est contraire à l'islam selon les
mollahs les bâches à poches sont
tolérées jusqu'à la puberté après elles
doivent redevenir des femmes à part
entière jacques n'a jamais eu
[Musique]
aujourd'hui elle ne veut plus abandonner
ses privilèges comme se promener dans
son costume d'homme avec sa meilleure
année
ce sera mieux d'aller dans le nouveau
centre que dans la vieille ville où on
sera plus tranquille
[Musique]
martonas j'ai de la chance de la
connaître ma famille motorisés aller
faire les magasins avec elle
[Musique]
j'ai même le droit d'aller chez elle
sans elle je ne ferai rien mais non
dans le centre ville les rares femmes
qui s'y trouvent sont en burqa la rue
appartient aux hommes
avec son costume occidental jacques ne
passe pas inaperçu mais hélas protégé
par la présence de son ami se fond dans
la foule jacques est hélas un frère et
une soeur un couple mais certainement
pas de jeune fille
allons voir la barre sans doute que tu
vas aimer très tôt
à
[Musique]
oui c'est joli c'est
la seule fois où j'ai porté des
vêtements de filles ça n'a duré qu'une
heure
c'était à cause de mon père il m'avait
frappé pour que je le fasse pour que je
change
je ne les ai porté qu'une
mais je me suis dit si je dois rester
comme ça
je vais me tuer
tu veux dire que tu voulais vraiment
tout de suite oui parce que je n'aime
pas porter des vêtements de filles
je vais être un garçon
pour faire ce que les garçons ont le
droit de faire
tout doux tout d'abord
les gestes donne un prénom donne une
allure d'homme dans un corps de femme
sous une identité de femme
en deux
bill qui a choisi de vivre en marge
contre les règles de la société
jacques 1
aïe et le soir et le jouer au
cerf-volant avec son petit frère
elle cache son corps de femme et enferme
sa poitrine dans une gaine
contrairement à ses soeurs elles ne
participent pas aux tâches domestiques
jacques veut être libre chaque ne se
mariera pas à 25 ans elle a renoncé à
fonder une famille est peut-être à
l'amour
des peurs route et j'aime quand les gens
me prennent pour un garçon
mais je n'aime pas avoir de relation
comme avec un petit ami une petite amie
je ne suis pas comme vous dites en
occident
et lesbiennes
je ne pense pas à ça
et tu ne te sens pas seul parfois
si ça m'arrive de me sentir seul
parmi mes trois soeurs une et marié une
autre va se marier bientôt et je sais
que moi je resterai seul
[Musique]
et même si parfois je me sens seule je
me dis que je vais travailler dur et
faire quelque chose de bien de ma vie
même si c'est difficile je préfère cette
vie car je les choisis
jacques a rencontré et là au lycée elle
est une des rares personnes hors de la
famille à connaître sa double identité
le secret de jacques d'autres afghane ne
partage
sous les voiles obligatoire dans les
écoles de filles elles taisent leurs
différences elle se plie et attendent
que leur reviennent
mariam est de celles là elle a 14 ans et
une conviction jamais elle ne sera comme
les autres
m
[Musique]
mariam est une bâche à poche depuis
qu'elle a quatre ans aujourd'hui c'est
une adolescente qui refuse de rentrer
dans le rang seule concession porter le
voile pour se rendre à l'école
depuis que je suis toute petite je
déteste porter le voile mais là je suis
bien obligé je ne peux pas faire
autrement
[Musique]
dans la tradition afghane les filles
doivent porter des vêtements qui
dissimule tout le corps et se couvrir la
tête c'est la tenue islamique que les
écolières revêtent dès leur plus jeune
âge
pour ces adolescentes aller à l'école
est un privilège dans un pays où 80 %
des filles sont illettrés
pour marianne l'école et ses uniformes
sont une contrainte
[Musique]
aucune de ses camarades ne sait vraiment
qui elle est
entre les murs de la classe elle vit
dans le mensonge
et dans l'ennui
[Musique]
c'est après les cours qu'elle est
elle-même son sac de sport sur le dos et
cheveux courts sous une casquette elles
bravent les regards et affirme sa
différence
tous les jours mariam se rend à son
entraînement de tennis pour trois heures
au moins elle y retrouve ses coéquipiers
des garçons essentiellement mariam joue
dans l'équipe nationale féminine elle a
commencé quand elle avait dix ans est
aujourd'hui la meilleure joueuse
d'afghanistan
[Musique]
je n'ai pas beaucoup d'amies filles je
m'entraîne avec ses garçons et ce sont
tous mes camarades
ils savent que tu es une bâche à poche
oui mais je ne lui dis pas n'importe qui
seulement à mes vrais amis et eux ils
sont comme mes frères
mariam est une des rares joueuses qui
peut participer aux compétitions
internationales
parce qu'elle est une bâche à poches
séparant la laisse voyager ce qui n'est
pas le cas des deux autres joueuses du
club
moi j'aime avoir les cheveux longs je ne
veux pas les couper et surtout pas
porter des vêtements de garçons comme
marianne
mais c'est vrai que vu la situation en
afghanistan ce n'est pas facile pour
nous les filles comme nous on ne peut
rien faire là on a de la chance nos
parents nous autorise à jouer au tennis
mais bientôt on devrait arrêter car nos
familles n'aime pas ça
monsieur vous êtes au courant
la dernière fois en iran il ya un joueur
iranien qui est venu pour saluer mariam
il s'apprêtait à la prendre dans ses
bras comme un garçon je lui ai dit fais
gaffe c'est une fille vous n'avez pas
remarqué
ses camarades ne se moque pas il la
respecte pour le club mariam est une
recrue en or à l'étranger elle défend à
elle seule les couleurs féminines de
l'afghanistan son entraîneur l'a déjà
emmené dans des tournois en iran et au
pakistan
c'est bien variable dépité jambes
elle a un vrai caractère de garçons
en afghanistan très peu de fillon sont
les ans elles sont mal à l'aise elles
ont honte de faire du sport
ils veulent surtout se protéger et ne
pas tomber par exemple
elle elle n'est pas comme ça elle a du
courage elle a le courage des garçons
c'est une fille mais pas vraiment en
fait
je lui donnais une fois pourquoi elle ne
mettait jamais de robe elle m'a dit
parce que je déteste ça
[Musique]
à quelques centaines de mètres de là
dans la cité d'époque soviétique ou
maria m'habite elle est observée
tout le monde a remarqué cette fille qui
ne ressemble à aucune autre et chacun
sait que cette fantaisie de brasser
c'est
dans la chambre qu'elle partage avec
l'une de ses deux soeurs ses vêtements
étalés sur le lit ressemblent à ceux
d'une ado européenne mais ici il détonne
et maman en fait quelque chose et
recommence mais arrête je veux juste que
tu essaies ça pour te couvrir les fesses
non non non mais a laissé juste pour
essayer
non allez juste une fois
donc tant pis pour toi
et toi tu es d'accord pour qu'elle sorte
comme ça avec des vêtements de garçons
non d'ici deux ou trois ans elle
changera d'elle-même de gré ou de force
et si elle ne veut pas la question ne se
pose pas elle le fera oui elle le fera
mais ça ne veut vraiment pas
bien sûr qu'elle le fera
ce n'est pas elle qui choisit c'est la
société c'est comme ça
elle changera c'est sûr à 100% et toi tu
en penses quoi tu es d'accord non on n'a
pas du tout
la légende familiale veut que ce soit
mariam qui est décidé elle-même d'être
une bâche à poches quand les talibans
diriger l'afghanistan la famille
s'étaient réfugiés au pakistan c'est là
que mariam la petite dernière haute
comme trois pommes a voulu prendre le
rôle du grand frère dans cette famille
où le père était souvent absent où il
n'y avait que des filles
[Musique]
je me sens complètement filles par
rapport à moi ou à ma famille je veux
juste me montrer comme un garçon
vis-à-vis de l'extérieur pour vivre
comme eux c'est comme ça depuis que je
me connais moi-même j'aime ce que je
suis depuis que j'ai adopté ce style
parfois je me bats avec des garçons je
n'ai pas de frère mais je joue ce rôle
là je veux je veux seront là j'aime ça
je me souviens je devais avoir 4 5 ans
un garçon un voisin insulté ma soeur à
l'époque je me suis battu avec lui il
est allé voir ma mère pour se plaindre
mais ma mère m'a soutenu elle ne m'a
rien dit j'ai compris que mon rôle était
bien de protéger mes soeurs
et tu ne préférerait pas avoir un frère
pour faire ça si j'avais un frère il ne
se comporteraient pas bien et ne me
laisseraient pas être comme ça je
préfère ne pas avoir deux frères et être
moi même le garde du corps de ma mère et
de ma soeur
je préfère que ce soit moi qui assume ce
rôle
[Musique]
mariam pratiquer le taekwondo elle est
championne de tennis elle adore regarder
le catch à la télé
mais chez elle son territoire se
restreint chaque jour un peu plus
dans cet univers féminin au milieu de
ses soeurs
mariam se réfugie dans ses rêves et ses
passe-temps
les soeurs sont étudiantes mais elle se
prépare déjà à leur destin construire
une famille
combien de temps l'ado rebelle
résistera-t-elle encore face aux assauts
de sa famille et de la société
mariam c'est que ces heures sont
comptées un jour elle aussi devra être
femme et se marier
[Musique]
un jour elle se peindre a les ongles
comme nahid
nahid 19 ans ancien pacha poche rentrer
dans le rang il y a trois ans
tu te souviens quand tu as mis du vernis
sur les ongles la première fois c'était
il ya trois ans ouais c'est ça j'avais
16 ans
et c'est toi qui a décidé de changer
non je n'ai jamais décidé moi même de
changer c'est la société qui m'a obligé
à changer
et maintenant tu te sens bien
je me sens plus à l'aise dans le sens où
les gens ne me jugent plus ne m'insulte
plus mais je n'aime pas ça
aujourd'hui nahid a trouvé un petit
travail elle fait la mise en page du
magazine de la fédération de football
d'afghanistan c'est son refuge ici
personne ne la juge sur son passé sur
ses choix
vous étiez au courant que c'était une
bâche à poches avant bien sûr
je n'ai pas compris tout de suite quand
elle a commencé à changer et à redevenir
filles ça m'a surpris
mais naturellement elle a grandi et elle
doit porter des vêtements féminins c'est
comme ça
nahid est connu à la fédération elle
fait partie de l'équipe féminine
d'afghanistan depuis cinq ans depuis que
les afghanes sont autorisés à jouer au
foot
j'aime bien le regarder quand je jouais
à cette époque
je me sentais bien comme ça
j'étais bien dans ma peau quand j'étais
bacha poche
j'étais libre comme un garçon
nahid numéro 7 cheveux courts en short
les jambes nues sans entrave
vous comprenez ce qu'elle veut dire
oui
ici c'est une société patriarcale le
pouvoir et aux hommes
[Musique]
une fois par semaine au moins l'aïd et
ses copines reprennent le pouvoir
talons aiguilles au pied et regard
décidé elles se rendent en taxi à leur
entraînement de foot
il y à nadia la gardienne de but et aura
la capitaine avec elle souffle un vent
de liberté et nahid retrouve ses
sensations du passé
je me sens de nouveau libre quand je
suis avec les autres filles j'ai
vraiment eu de la chance de les
rencontrer
quand on est ensemble comme ça on s'en
fout de ce que les gens pensent s'ils se
disent ce sont des filles bien ou pas il
nous voit on est dans un taxi on va
jouer au foot on s'en fiche de ce qu'il
pense certaines personnes pensent ça de
vous non pas certaines personnes tout
par exemple quand on parle ensemble on
rigole et tous les gens autour de nous
nous montre du doigt sur
vous voyez ces mauvaises filles qui sont
en train de rire et de marcher dans la
rue
quand elle était bacha poche nahid jouer
au foot c'était une passion
aujourd'hui qu'elle est une fille c'est
un acte de rébellion et de courage
aujourd'hui
à
[Musique]
tous
pour éviter les insultes l'équipe
nationale de foot féminin a trouvé
refuge dans les quartiers de l'otan
derrière checkpoint et barbelés
[Musique]
tu
auger oui
après dix minutes de marche un terrain
de sport protéger des regards salut ça
va
25 filles toute l'équipe nationale
[Musique]
dans les vestiaires les joueuses
n'oublie pas les règles de décence
pas un centimètre de peau ne doit
apparaître vous avez vu mon maillot
quand j'étais bacha poche je pouvais
porter des grandes chaussettes et un
short j'avais des gens nus
maintenant c'est fini
si vous voulez jouer au foot en
afghanistan il faut s'habiller islamique
en cinq années l'équipe nationale
féminine est devenue le symbole du
combat des femmes contre les interdits
pour en arriver là ces filles ont dû
convaincre leurs parents ignorer les
insultes et pour certaines les menaces
l'entraîneur ancien gardien de but de
l'équipe nationale de l'afghanistan
prend lui même des risques à venir ici
pour une majorité d'afghans ces filles
sont la honte du pays
ses joueuses sont l'espoir du pays elles
peuvent apporter le changement en venant
ici et on joue au foot alors j'encourage
toutes leurs soeurs à en faire autant
je vous remercier
pour nahid la parenthèse aura été de
courte durée
dès la fin de l'entraînement elle doit
rentrer chez elle avant que la nuit ne
tombe surtout
l'essentiel de sa vie depuis qu'elle
n'est plus bas sa poche se résume au mur
de sa maison c'est une maison de femmes
un foyer fragile la mère de nahid a fui
son mari violent elle s'est réfugiée
dans l'anonymat de kaboul pour oublier
la honte qui pesait sur elle et ses
enfants dans sa province du nord du pays
j'ai passé une bonne journée oui tu as
préparé quoi manger durée après avoir
autorisé sa fille à devenir bacha poche
elle l'a obligé à quitter ses manières
d'hommes
être une bâche à poche ce n'est pas mal
en soi je n'avais rien contre eux j'ai
autorisé ma fille à vivre comme elle le
souhaitait du moment qu'elle se
comportait bien du point de vue de la
morale
jusqu'à ce que les gens me posent
problème quand il te demandais si
j'étais une fille ou un garçon oui les
gens me disaient il fallait changer mais
rien n'a vraiment changé elles pensent
comme un garçon elle ressent les choses
comme un garçon haïtien qu'elle veut
faire c'est ce que font les gars sont
allés dehors travailler elle fait des
économies pour être indépendante et pour
pouvoir étudier
nahid avait 10 ans quand ses parents se
sont séparés c'est à ce moment là
qu'elle a décidé de devenir une bâche à
poche elle s'est coupé les cheveux pour
être l'homme de la maison elle voulait
prendre sa revanche sur les dominateurs
sa mère a laissé faire
j'avais ça en tête à ce moment là
si dieu m'avait donné le choix entre
être un garçon ou une fille j'aurais
choisi d'être un garçon
qu'il ya trop d'inégalités ici
devant le tribunal par exemple une femme
aura forcément tort le jugement sera
toujours en sa défaveur
ils sont les plus forts ici
c'est pour ça que je voulais être un
homme
maintenant je vis avec l'espoir que dieu
change quelque chose dans ma vie
ce n'est pas le cas je ne sais pas ce
qui va se passer
il faut tuer qu'ils changent tu sais
bien maman je voudrais faire de la
politique
devenir un symbole apporter l'espoir aux
nouvelles générations
ou alors enseigner à l'université la
politique
transmettre à mes étudiants mes
convictions et ma force il ya
qu'ils changent ce pays
ou alors être élu au parlement
ou bien à vos 4
enfin tout ça ce sont des rêves
et je voudrais te marier un jour s'il ya
bien une chose que je déteste c'est le
mariage
qu'elle vous voulez qu'elle se marie ah
oui avec un bon garçon en afghanistan en
afghanistan bien sûr et rapidement car
sinon après il sera trop vieille c'est
comme ça à l'afghanistan
elle n'a pas de frère pas de père elle
doit subvenir à ses besoins
ces bâches à poches sont un défi à
l'ordre établi
celle qui refuse de rentrer dans le rang
de devenir des femmes et de se marier
sont en danger et leurs proches aussi
[Musique]
la famille de jacques le sait le soir
elles se barricade
en souvenir de cette nuit de l'été 2007
il était minuit quand un groupe d'homme
est arrivé
il avait caché leur visage il y en avait
quatre ici 80 et 4 dehors douze au total
ils ont pointé leurs armes sur moi et
ils m'ont frappé
ils m'ont dit où est jacques
je leur ai dit jacques n'est pas là
jacques était à la maison
et moi je l'entendais crier
puis sont rentrés ils ont éteint les
lumières ils ont pris nos téléphones
portables
ils sont venus par là et il appelait
jacques
jacques n'était pas là non plus
c'était une oreille de nuit en cauchemar
et vous savez où elle était jacques
était un art au fond de ce trou
quand ils sont partis je vais tirer de
là elle pleurait elle n'arrêtait pas de
pleurer pendant des semaines elle n'a
pas pu dormir la maison dans meilleur
dans la famille
je ne pensais pas que je m'en sortirai
vivante je me disais ils vont trouver et
me tuer
de minuit à 2h30 du matin la famille de
jacques avaient été rassemblées dans une
autre pièce les mains liées dans le dos
la police n'a jamais retrouvé ce qu'ils
cherchaient jacques la bâche à poche
celles qui refusaient de vivre comme une
afghane
on était là
bien sûr que je suis heureuse de vivre à
kaboul c'est là qu'est ma famille ma
patrie mais ma vie devient trop
dangereuse
moi quand je vais dehors je n'ai pas
peur mais je crains pour la sécurité de
ma famille
ils sont en danger
à cause de moi à cause de mes choix
je suis fier d'elle c'est quelqu'un de
respectable et de pure ce n'est pas une
mauvaise fille
si ça avait été le cas je l'aurait forcé
à changer et à se marier c'est une femme
forte qui veut mettre son énergie au
service des autres et c'est pour ça que
je lui ai laissé sa liberté
mais le problème c'est que ce n'est pas
acceptée dans notre société il ya
tellement de barrières elle se bat
contre sais je suis fier de ma fille
c'est ma fille adorée je ne laisserai
personne me faire du mal
je ne veux pas qu'elles soient en danger
[Musique]
malgré la peur jacques n'a pas enfoui
ses rêves au fond de ce trou elle n'a
pas renoncé
en
la journée jacques travail elle
supervise un programme d' aide à
l'éducation des femmes pour une
fondation afghane
c'est parce qu'elle est une femme
qu'elle est admise dans les classes de
quartier auprès de ses petites filles
leur père refuse de les laisser aller à
l'école publique trop loin grâce à ce
programme elles apprennent à lire et
écrire
c'est comme cela que jacques se sentent
utiles
[Musique]
voici l'allemagne nous irons à berlin en
avion on ira en belgique par le train
est ensuite paris
voici celles pour qui jacques travail
massouda jalal une figure politique de
l'afghanistan elle a été ministre du
gouvernement karzaï en 2004 sa fondation
est invité pour une tournée de
conférences en europe sur la situation
des femmes en afghanistan au moment du
retrait des troupes de l'otan mes amis
nous allons là bas pour rappeler au
monde qu'il faut faire attention à ce
qui se passe dans notre pays en ce
moment les droits civiques sont bafoués
et le droit des femmes est menacée avec
le retrait des troupes internationales
il faut leur dire que nous avons peur
vous voulez dire qu'on doit raconter
toute la réalité
elle a choisi quatre femmes de sa
fondation pour témoigner des professeurs
et des avocates jacques et parmi elles
à camara salle est ouverte d'esprit tu
as chez ace c'est une personnalité
libre
elle a le soutien de sa famille
notamment d'un père
compréhensif chez free
elle est libre dans sa vie elle a le
contrôle de son emploi du temps
elle peut faire ses propres choix
je fonde beaucoup d'espoir en elle
je voudrais qu'elle est une bourse
d'études à l'étranger
qu'elle se perfectionne et qu'elle
revienne pour être un leader de la
nouvelle génération note dennis stock
aniston c'est pour ça que j'ai choisi et
que je l'aide
c'est ce que tu veux aussi oui
pour jacques le rêve d'un destin à part
commencent à se réaliser
avec cette invitation obtenir un
passeport pour l'europe devient possible
un avenir bien différents se profile
pour marianne la pression se resserre
autour de l'adolescente elles passent
toujours ces après-midi sur le court de
tennis
mais son père a décidé d'aller consulter
le mollah de la mosquée
[Musique]
le mollah nous reçoit avec le père de
marianne qu'il connaît le phénomène des
bâches à poches et leurs excuses au nom
de l'islam
certaines filles s'habillent comme des
garçons pour avoir plus de liberté
distel que pensez vous d'elle est en
achat ça n'a pas de sens une femme ne
peut pas gagner la liberté juste en
changeant de vêtements
ce n'est pas de la liberté qu'elles
gagnent et de la souffrance
elle perd le respect et devient une
insulte à la société
et puis les femmes sont libres elle peut
voyager avec leur mari elles peuvent
sortir de chez elle accompagnée par des
proches
tout ça ce n'est pas un problème
londres des mollahs pèse sur les vaches
approche
et elle
pour mariam il est temps de tourner la
page de l'enfance à 14 ans elle est une
adulte qui n'a plus droit à l'innocence
ses envies et ses peurs sa famille doit
les étouffer une question d'honneur
et
les repas familiaux se transforme de
plus en plus souvent en conseil de
famille
[Musique]
le mollah a dit que tu pouvais porter
les vêtements de garçons situent les
recouvrait d'un vêtement long sur tout
le corps
il a dit que porter des jeans et des
vêtements islamiques n'étaient pas
incompatibles
ici tu le sais bien les filles ne sont
pas obligées de porter la burqa comme
dans le nord de l'afghanistan il faut
juste que tu sois en règle et tu peux
même continuer à faire du sport mais
fait un effort
oui je sais tout ça
le problème c'est que je vais comme je
suis depuis que je suis toute petite et
vous ma famille vous m'avez soutenu et
je vous en suis très reconnaissante
mais vous savez que je ne supporte pas
de porter un voile je sais que je vis
ici mais laissez-moi voir comment la
société évolue ce qui va se passer et là
je prendrai ma décision
laissez moi encore un peu de temps
tiens j'ai ça aussi comme couleurs
[Applaudissements]
celles qui ont renoncé ne s'en remettra
jamais vraiment
nahid a repris l'apparence d'une femme
mais au fond d'elle rien n'a changé son
ami zohra est une des rares qui connaît
son passé de bacha poche sinon nahid
n'en parle jamais tu as apporté des
photos au fait ce week end a donc c'est
quand tu étais bacha poche oui c'était
quand
il ya trois ans
tu avais commencé le football
oui je venais juste de commencer
ça te paraît bizarre le fait qu'elle
portait des vêtements garçon avant
ce n'est pas si étrange pour moi
quand j'étais petite je voulais être un
garçon aussi non pas à cause du genre
mais pour la liberté
je voulais vivre comme un garçon
m'habiller comme un garçon
et surtout joué au foot comme
quand tu es une fille tu dois demander
pour tous demandé à ta mère et à ton
père pour tout et n'importe quoi et la
plupart du temps à la réponse est non
maintenant que tu es une fille est-ce
que tu as réussi à faire ce que tu
voulais
non pas encore par exemple qu'aurais tu
fait de différent si tu avais été un
garçon
si j'avais été un garçon par exemple
j'aurais pu travailler depuis longtemps
et gagner de l'argent
j'aurais pu en faire ce que je voulais
et en l'occurrence je l'aurais
économiser pour me payer des études
et là j'aurais déjà passer mes examens
je serai entre l université
et là je suis sûr que j'aurai réussi
à ce qui aurait pu se passer si j'avais
été un garçon
mais tu sais ce n'est pas trop tard
c'est vrai que les filles on a plus de
difficultés comme le fait qu'on n'ait
pas le droit de jouer au foot je les
regarde on a réussi on joue au foot
quand même ce n'est pas vrai
tu vas trouver ta voix en tant que femme
tu vas voir
zohra et nahid deux jeunes femmes qui
apprennent à composer qui relève la tête
et cultivent leur jardin secret jusqu'à
ce qu'un jour il leur soit possible de
vivre à découvert de ne plus se cacher
dans la cave pour taper dans un ballon
et se dérober aux regards des voisins
[Musique]
est-ce que vous ne jouez pas dehors
parce que vous le savez ici une fille
bien le joue pas au foot
[Musique]
m
vous aimez kaboul et vous
j'adore kaboul s'ils sont les gens que
je n'aime pas
ah bon mais tu veux dire tous les
habitants où seulement les hommes
[Musique]
non je suis plus en colère contre la
faim fait
que les hommes veuille dominer les
femmes c'est normal c'est naturel
mais que les femmes cautionne ça c'est
ça que je n'accepte pas et qui me met en
colère
tu es d'accord nahid points
[Musique]
octobre 2011 nous rejoignons l'europe
porte d'entrée
berlin via istanbul
[Musique]
à l'arrivée ces deux hommes attendent
avec impatience les cinq femmes venues
d'afghanistan ils ne se sont jamais
rencontrés
c'est la première fois qu'elle vienne en
europe
[Musique]
en mai
bonjour c'est de la fondation jeanne
elle
ils font partie d'une fondation
européenne d'études sur l'asie du sud
est ont monté ce projet avec la
fondation de massoud a pour faire
entendre la cause des femmes afghanes
enchanté c'est un honneur de vous
recevoir ici
merci merci beaucoup
mais ressent propres
oui c'est beau
pourquoi les talibans ne viennent pas
ici ils n'ont rien à faire ici les
talibans c'est que pour nous
malheureusement que dieu l'ait me disent
ils détruisent leur propre pays ici il
ne serait rien
à
l'hôtel elles sont attendues pour leur
première conférence
autour d'elle des élus des militants des
droits de l'homme des universitaires
il s'interroge que va devenir
l'afghanistan après le retrait des
troupes internationales en 2014
de grands dangers en afghanistan
les corps notamment dit m un appareil de
sexe en haïti
après la guerre le pouvoir tombe entre
les mains des extrémistes
ce sera un fascisme religieux à une
dictature religieuse qui commencera
j'espère que la communauté
internationale
comprendra attend et stoppera la montée
des extrémismes en afghanistan
les mines afghanistan
un message que les cinq femmes vont à la
sab le mans répété durant leur séjour
européen
avant de poursuivre leur route vers le
parlement de bruxelles puis paris et
genève elle s'offre une journée de
visite à berlin un premier contact avec
l'europe son histoire sa culture ses
modes de vie jacques semble fasciner
et l'allégresse gagne peu à peu la
petite troupe
imagine si l'afghanistan devenues comme
ça
depuis que j'ai mis les pieds ici je me
sens bien je suis à l'aise en
afghanistan on me voit comme une bâche à
poches et les gens me jugent ici je suis
heureuse quand je vois que les autres
filles ne sont pas vraiment différente
de moi elle s'habille comme moi ce sont
toutes des bâches la poche en fait
[Musique]
après quatre jours de voyage et
conférence dit voici à paris elle me
targue et moi ça me dit à moi-même j'ai
vraiment de la chance d'être là
laisse moi faire tu vas voir moi c'est
très
bien mais tu as la lumière post m la
première fois que je fais ça
c'est bon j'en ai assez
non l'asthme ou encore j'aime bien faire
ça
[Musique]
alex présent grec maison
et puis sur les hauteurs de montmartre
elle réalise que dans cet autre monde
elle aurait pu être quelqu'un d'autre
un
peu jalouse quand je vois les gens des
endroits magnifiques comme celui là
mais je voudrais tant que l'afghanistan
ressemble à ça un jour
mais je n'y crois plus
si je venais ici si je vivais ici je
n'aurais plus de problème je pourrais
changer oui petit à petit je pourrais
devenir une femme
[Musique]
e
nous n'avions rien vu venir les femmes
de la délégation non plus
un soir elle nous ont appelés pour nous
prévenir quand nous sommes arrivés à
leur hôtel parisien elle était en pleurs
jacques avait disparu dell ne restait
que ces chaussures d'homme
jbk l'airbag elle a tout pris son sac
son ordinateur comme but
à part ses chaussures et quelques
vêtements
[Musique]
tant pis claude c'est
tout ouais elle a laissé sa une veste et
une chemise et son pyjama
jamais je n'aurais imaginé ça je suis
très triste bach
il ne faut pas qu'elle reste ici il faut
qu'elle revienne avec nous en
afghanistan
[Musique]
ses amis ont attendu une journée son
retour en vain
massoud a est sous le choc elle cherche
des explications et a du mal à cacher sa
déception elle qui avait mis tant
d'espoirs en jacques
brest peut être que le fait de
s'habiller comme un homme
lui a donné d'une certaine manière
l'impression d'être un homme
et que du coup elle avait plus de
courage
elle s'est sentie capable de faire des
choses d'une autre femme n'aurait pu
faire
elle avait une sorte de confiance en
elle
après 24 heures d'absence et de silence
il leur faut se résoudre à signaler la
disparition de jacques à la police
c'est une personne qui a disparu de
notre délégation
la dernière fois qu'on l'a vu c'était
hier soir qu'est-ce qui est une raison
particulière pour ta personne disparaît
seul
jacques avait-elle préparé sa fuite est
elle partie sur un coup de tête
préférant la clandestinité en france au
mensonge en afghanistan
nous sommes retournés à kaboul quelques
semaines plus tard la délégation a
poursuivi son programme elles sont
revenus à quatre avec un goût amer après
l'inquiétude elles se sont sentis trahis
elle pensait que jacques reviendrai et
s'engagerait pour faire changer
l'afghanistan
sabina continue de se déguiser en garçon
pour travailler mais elle va à l'école
désormais deux heures par jour là elle
met son voile plein d'innocence elle
veut croire en son avenir
que veux tu faire plus tard capteurs
[Musique]
mariam résiste toujours elle profite de
sa liberté de bacha poche pour sortir le
soir avec ses copains du tennis
j'espère rester toute ma vie comme ça si
la situation le permet je serai une
bâche à eau jusqu'à ma mort
[Musique]
nahid plus déterminé que jamais voudrait
bien partir elle aussi quitté
l'afghanistan où elle ne trouve pas sa
place
partir sans se retourner comme jacques
quelques temps après la disparition de
leur fille ils ont eu des nouvelles elle
leur a téléphoné de france son visa
avait expiré mais elle semblait
confiante elle voulait tenter sa chance
la mère de jacques est inconsolable son
père parle d'elle au passé
elle ne pouvait plus vivre ici l été en
danger
c'était une fille pure elle me dit une
fois quand je serai en europe peut-être
que je pourrai être une femme parce qu
en afghanistan je ne pourrai jamais elle
avait sans doute déjà pris sa décision
celle de ne pas revenir
si j'avais su tous les problèmes qu'elle
aurai je n'aurais jamais fait d'elle une
bâche à poche
j'espère qu'elle pourra me donner des
nouvelles je voudrais tellement qu'elle
est ce qu'elle désire étant une vie
meilleure est libre je serai en paix si
c'est le cas et peut-être qu'elle
reviendra un jour
oh
où
[Musique]